hi i'm gayle simmons and we're making
spaghetti pie when i was 19 years old i
traveled to new zealand and australia
for the summer with my best friend and
college roommate camille one thing that
we noticed on our travels was that at
every truck stop they always had
spaghetti sandwiches which we thought
was pretty incredible this was long
before the carbs are scary days but it
was so delicious and i've always thought
about that sandwich i've never really
attempted to make my own but played
around a little bit in the kitchen and
came up with what i think is even better
the spaghetti pie i'm putting in a can
of whole tomatoes here and i'm going to
break them up a little bit you know
tongs are like an extended part of my
arm these whole tomatoes have so much
flavor and just the right amount of
liquid with them that you want as
opposed to a can of crushed tomatoes
where you kind of just get less tomato
flesh you want it to simmer for about
five minutes to reduce some of that
liquid and thicken the mixture but you
definitely want to make sure that
there's still a good amount of sauce
from cooking so much i've learned a few
things you definitely want enough salt
that the water tastes salty i mean you
don't want to dump a bucket of salt but
i estimate two tablespoons of salt for a
pound of pasta i just want to have great
food around at all times this is just
sort of perfect for everything it feeds
more people than you can believe it's
big
and it's rich and it's super delicious
it's easy to make and it feeds a lot of
people so don't think that you only have
to use it when you're cooking for 10
people i make it it feeds four and then
i put it in the fridge and i'm happy to
eat it for lunch i'm happy for my
daughter to have it for lunch eat it
late night as i said i find lots of
reasons to eat this buy no being shy
with the cheese
my mother was actually a cooking teacher
so when i was growing up i spent a lot
of time in the kitchen with her cooking
she taught cooking in our kitchen to
women in the neighborhood so i have a
lot of early memories of watching her
cook and eating the food that she would
make for her little cooking school we
ate a lot of unusual ingredients that
most kids didn't eat but truthfully when
i was growing up all i really wanted was
a hot dog and some mac and cheese like
everyone else could eat for lunch and my
mom was making zucchini and shadro i
don't know there was some weird stuff
but it was amazing and ultimately set me
on a horse
that made me who i am and obviously
taught me what i wanted to do the most
in my life but at the time you didn't
realize it the last thing you want when
you're graduating from college is for
everyone to tell you that you're just
like your mother and now i embrace it
it's like i couldn't run for my own
destiny you know
doesn't look ridiculously delicious
[Music]
just as good i remember
it still works
[Music]